bonjour nadège réouverture des terrasses
pour certains le voient derrière vous
mais pas pour tout le monde absolument
magali alors on est rue montorgueil
c'est une rue située en plein paris très
prisé par les parisiens avec de
nombreuses terrasses beaucoup de
restaurants beaucoup de bars de commerce
alors vous l'avez dit certains
restaurants vont donc pouvoir rouvrir
dès ce dès ce mercredi avec des
conditions très strictes pas plus de 6
et des écarts de 8 m² 1 / entre chaque
entre chaque table certains vont donc
rouvrir c'est une première depuis la fin
du mois d'octobre et le deuxième
confinement d'autres ne vont pas rouvrir
à l'image de ce restaurant ici qui le le
gérant estime et bien que la rentabilité
ne sera pas au rendez vous pour lui
comme pour d'autres dans cette autour de
cette rue montorgueil puisque la
terrasse est beaucoup trop petit et vu
les conditions
ça va pas être rentable pour lui de
rouvrir alors il ya d'autres obstacles
au delà des conditions assez strictes
qu'il faut respecter
on sait que le télétravail est encore
très pratiqué ici à paris et pas sûr que
les clients envahissent toutes ses
terrasses la météo fait des siennes
également ce mois de mai le temps est
particulièrement pluvieux et un peu
froid un peu plus que qu'à l'accoutumée
donc voilà plusieurs obstacles qui font
que pas sûr que les terrains soient
envahi en tout cas dès aujourd'hui donc
beaucoup beaucoup de restaurateurs vont
très certainement attendre la
réouverture totale de leur établissement
prévu donc pour le 9 juin prochain
on vous laisse prendre un café nadège
merci beaucoup c'est vrai qu'il n'ya pas
grand monde
il n'y a pas grand monde ce matin à
cause du mauvais temps vous allez
prendre un café dans quelques instants
d'abord une question la fin des aides de
l'état qui inquiète aussi beaucoup les
restaurateurs nadège alors qu'ils sont
autorisés à ouvrir fassiez partiellement
le pire pourrait être à venir pour eux
absolument magali vous l'avez dit un
millier de faillite désormais et
certains syndicats craignent que le
chiffre monte à 30 mille trente mille
bars et restaurants pourraient fermer
définitivement leurs portes en à cause
de la crise sanitaire alors l'autre
enjeu à partir d'aujourd'hui et ça va
être de faire revenir les clients dans
les secteurs touristique c'est un pari
loin d'être gagné après une année de
quasi confinement et les parisiens
auront très certainement une envie de
devoir ailleurs de partir l'année
dernière les chiffres du tourisme en
ile-de-france ont rarement été aussi
mauvais les pertes de recettes
atteignent en effet 6 4 milliards
d'euros c'est énorme
merci beaucoup nadège pour toutes ces
précisions nadège abderrazak en direct
de la rue de montorgueil à paris